very quickly i just want to mention
arsene wenger because he was here um
before christmas and you were there at
arsenal yeah for that changing of the
guard
were you one of those guys who were
really unhappy with all the
you know the new dietary requirements
all this discipline he
introduced i was devastated
you know you're talking about a black
man that needs seasoning on his food
you know so arsene wenger came in and
we're talking about
you know we'd probably have to eat eat
that
no salt no anything all we can do is
drink water
and eat food like the chicken literally
just boiled
and it just looks like just wrong you
know everything was just
you know it was just for fuel you
couldn't have tea
couldn't have tea couldn't have anything
i remember there was there was a time i
used to share a room with dennis burkham
and like dennis is the greatest player
i've ever played with and you know we
shared a room and we're total opposites
chocolate cheese and
personalities and once we started doing
it
dennis done it to the right to the max
man you know if the boss said
you drink you think drink a quarter pint
of water that's what he would do
i would still drink i'd drink a pint of
water but the thing is
i remember i snuck in some tea bags and
um
so rock and roll yeah
i snuck in some tea bags and i remember
dennis he was just on
he's just on the bed because he was
sitting there watching to tell him he
said is that tea bags i said
yeah he said but the boss doesn't want
us to drink tea
he said yeah but he doesn't know what's
he gonna say yeah okay said yeah
okay so the whole teams do but you're
not gonna do it so when we need you most
you're probably gonna let us down
because
you're
[Laughter]
so in the end i didn't have the tea and
then i didn't have the tea because at
the end of the day
what we went on to do with that team
because of him yeah
is because we all added to what he
wanted us to do he's an amazing man he's
an amazing man